So here's that javascript code from before,
with the anonymous function assigned
to "greeter" nested inside "makegreeter."
I'm going to draw the environment much more formally.
In our global environment, "greeting" points to "hola."
"Makegreeter" is a function with three other components
that I'm not showing right now,
and "sayhello"--well, to figure out its value,
I'm going to have to call "makegreeter" on "hello."
Whenever I call a function, I make a new frame
with just enough room for all of the formal parameters.
Then inside this frame I'm adding a new
local variable, "greeter," which is a function with one parameter.
And even with our environment bug,
even with the bug that we've been considering,
this is still going to point back to the global frame.
So this value of "greeter"--this function defined here--will be copied back.
And these things I've marked in green have the same value.
This was the return value of "makegreeter," so it's what "sayhello" currently has.
And now we're going to call "sayhello" on "gracie."
So we're going to make a new frame
where a person points to "gracie" pointing back to the global frame.
And here's the question for you--
one of these arrows, or possibly both, is incorrect,
if we have the bug we've currently been talking about.
We have the bug.
Check the arrow--check the parent pointer edge
that would be different if we didn't have the bug.
If we fixed the bug, how does the world change--quiz?